tonight and joining me now is dr. ben
Carson Secretary of House and Housing
and Urban Development dr. Carson I want
to go back to this during the the Senate
hearing today where lawmakers did press
doctor foul a on the consequences of
keeping schools closed watch I think the
one size fits all that we're gonna have
a national strategy and nobody's gonna
go to school is kind of ridiculous was a
huge mistake if we don't open the
schools in the fall as there had been
any sort of kind of risk benefit ratio
for the child particular risk for
missing out on a year of education
particularly for those from less than
rich backgrounds unattended deleterious
consequences of having children out of
school we fully appreciate that I don't
have an easy two that I just don't
is that a little troubling that this is
where we are we as a member of the task
force what do you think needs to happen
now parents across the country are
freaking out that their kids are not
going to go back to school next fall you
know one of the reasons that that we
have a president is so that they can
weigh all these different opinions that
come from all kinds of different
directions and the president's doing a
good job of that I expect people in the
scientific arena to always be dotting
all the i's and crossing all the t's and
always being extra cautious particularly
if they're physicians but that's the
reason probably that they're not the
ones who make all the decisions you have
to have somebody who can integrate all
these things and obviously one size does
not fit all that is so important and you
know this is the land of the free maybe
sometimes people forget that but you
know there's a reason that America rose
from nowhere to the pinnacle of the
world in record time it's because we had
people who were free to use their gifts
their innovation their entrepreneurship
and we had people who were brave people
who are willing to take risk
unfortunately there is no risk-free
atmosphere and we have to weigh these
things you know when you look at the
hotlines for mental illness and
substance abuse they skyrocketed in
April and you look at all the the
negative consequences that come from
sequestering people we have to begin to
think about those things as well and
weigh these things does it mean that we
don't have to be careful we've learned a
lot of things we've learned about
hand-washing we've learned about social
distancing we've learned of be careful
about the things that we touch all this
social distancing all these things are
important and if we use them
intelligently we can integrate people
back into the workforce this country was
built on work it wasn't built on sitting
around and waiting for the government to
do everything for you are you concerned
that what you're seeing in in states
especially that have much of their state
is very little covent I mean
proportionally very small especially
compared to the horrific flu season we
had which was one of the worst in the
last I think 40 years are the last flu
season although the CDC can't get its
numbers straight on that but are you are
you worried that this response by some
state and local officials is appearing
to be more politically based than
medically based well either that or it's
a great coincidence I'm not sure I would
love it if all the governors and all the
local officials would simply say let's
sit down and look at the evidence
remember for instance in Georgia there
was all this criticism a few weeks ago
because of governor Kemp said I'm going
to open things up well he did open
things up have we had a tremendous spike
there if we have I haven't heard about
it now I know we need to be wilting we
need to be willing to really sit down
and objectively look at the data and
look at the data on both sides what is
the damage from contracting the virus
what is the damage from destroying the
economy and look at the long-term
implications of that and I think you'll
come out on the right side if you're
willing to do that
The Washington Post headline I just
tweeted it a few moments ago dr. Carson
100,000 businesses are set to close more
than a hundred thousand small businesses
have closed forever as the nation's
pandemic toll escalates that's a lot of
human lives don't you think
absolutely and every day that we keep
things shuttered more businesses will
close now there is a good thing 22nd of
the lot of the brush has burned off and
a new businesses will spring up because
the infrastructure is still there dr.
Carson sorry to cut you off thanks for
joining